Is there a new circulated tumor test within the United States that is new and our doctors can order? I thought you mentioned one a few months ago.
No, so there are circulated tumor tests and I don't think you're asking the right question.
I'm not in favor of doing circulated tumor test. There's lots of circulated tumor test.
But to me, there's no value in measuring circulating tumor cells.
To me, there's no value at all. Are you taking a blood sample and say, are there any circulated tumor cells in there? Well, what to do? What do you care? I mean, your body is your tumor is given off circulating tumor cells at some point of time.
And the ones that are circulating in your blood, if there are already, I mean, you know, that doesn't that doesn't give us any.
It doesn't help us in the cause of care. So you just have to assume you have circulated tumor cells in the tissue somewhere, somewhere.
That's why even if you get a full clean bill of cancer, you know, you still keep doing your right, could still keep doing stuff because, you know, darn well, that you're a realist.
You're not, you know, this screaming optimist and you're not a, you're not a negative person, but you're a realist and you're like, okay, well, I'm sure I got cancer cells somewhere. So I'm going to continue doing this stuff so it doesn't just take off and, you know, raise a family of million kids and now we got a problem.
So, you know, I don't think there's any value or do a circulated tumor sense test. So if you're looking about your question is really about other test that can measure whether your cancer growth or not.
Very, there is a tendency you certainly can do.
Watch that video on the website, how the way to improve it, there are two more suppressing tumor marker test that a person can do a social positive and other things that you can do to measure success or not.